Last Saturday was my mom's birthday.
Did you buy anything special for her?
No, I didn't buy anything for her.
I cleaned the house and cooked dinner instead.
Then did your mom get nothing for her birthday?
My brother gave her a bunch of flowers and a hair pin.
My dad bought her a beautiful dress and a scarf!
Wow.
She might be very happy.
My dad wants nothing for Father's Day.
Last year I gave him a tie and now he has enough ties.
My sister gave him a hat and now he has enough hats.
My brother gave him socks and now he has enough socks.
Mom gave him a computer game and now he has enough games.
This year, Dad wants nothing but we have a plan.
We will watch TV, watch TV.
We will play, play, play.
And we will give him the biggest hug just for Father's Day.